antoine vous êtes au colin vous suivez
cette rencontre ce mec est ce qu'il faut
retenir des premiers échanges face
caméra entre les deux dirigeants tout à
l'heure
il ya tout d'abord que vladimir poutine
s'est dit être réjouis d'accueillir
emmanuel macron au kremlin presque deux
ans après leur dernière rencontre
l'occasion pour eux de discuter de
plusieurs problématiques l'ukraine en
premier lieu vous l'avais dit en
profondeur mais aussi dans un format
plus personnel que de simple
conversation téléphonique le président
russe a également rappelé à son
homologue qu'il n'était pas le premier
président français à se frotter à la
crise ukrainienne je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait je vois aussi que
les autorités présentes le président
français
appliqué de gros efforts pour régler la
crise relative à la sécurité européenne
pour la perspective historique cela
concerne également les sujets relatifs
au règlement de la crise entre
ukrainienne à l'est du pays
durant nos échanges téléphoniques nous
avons abordé en détail
ses aspects je sais que toi tu as sa
vision et je suis vraiment heureux
d'avoir l'opportunité de te voir en
direct et en présentiel soient
bienvenues
on l'a entendu le président russe
considère que la france et son président
sont en effet impliqués dans la
résolution des problèmes fondamentaux de
la sécurité européenne en témoigne
encore une fois élus ont évoqué les
appels téléphoniques fréquents et
constant entre les deux présidents là en
face après l'intervention de lanières
poutine et mme harel macron avec un
visage plutôt fermé a évoqué une
situation critique en europe qu'il est
bien décidé en lien avec ses alliés
européens et l'otan à tendre vers une
désescalade écoutez
ce dialogue est nécessaire car c'est le
seul qui permet à mes yeux de bâtir une
vraie sécurité stabilité pour le
continent européen c'est pourquoi le
contexte actuel nous avons eu ces
dernières semaines plusieurs échanges
téléphoniques tu l'a rappelé et tous ces
derniers mois au demeurant malgré la
crise j'ai pu aussi échangé avec le
président aziz qui pour ce qui est de
l'ukraine mais nous coordonner avec
de nombreux européens et alliés
qu'il s'agisse aussi des britanniques ou
des américains des canadiens et je pense
que la discussion d'aujourd'hui à mes
yeux
amorcé une
ce vers quoi nous devons aller qui est
une une désescalade dont nous
connaissons d'ailleurs les termes la
situation politico-militaire
la question ne craignait donc lui
rappeler l'importance et le format
normandie la situation sécuritaire en
biélorussie et dans toute la région et
les grandes questions évidemment de
sécurité collective dont nous allons
parler
cela fait maintenant un peu plus d'une
heure quinze que les deux hommes
discutent derrière portes closes et
c'est à l'issue de leurs pourparlers que
les deux hommes vont se présenter face à
la presse et antoine un mot sur
l'arrivée d'emmanuel macron du côté de
moscou lorsque l'avion a atterri
pourquoi cette descente d'avion des
manuels macron at elle duré autant de
temps
oui bien apparemment l'intégralité des
passagers de ce vol a dû être testés
avant de pouvoir descendre de l'appareil
en effet ici les autorités sont très à
cheval sur toute cette protection
sanitaire nous mêmes tous les
journalistes qui sont présents au
kremlin aujourd'hui ont dû passer trois
tests contre le coc vide ces quatre
derniers jours et même en arrivant un
nouveau test un test antigénique afin de
pouvoir accéder à la salle de presse
merci anthony caro pour toutes ces
précisions en direct donc du kremlin à
moscou